This is an Apple AirTag.
And six months ago...
I used one of them to chase Tom
all the way across London.
And I came very, very close
to finding you.
You came so close.
You've got the AirTag this time.
I'm tracking you.
We're on your home turf
in Nottingham.
Yes.
The rules are roughly the same.
You've got a list of tasks.
You get a point for
each one you complete.
Your job is to beat my
seven tasks from last time.
My job is to tag you first.
Okay. Eight points.
You've got one hour.
Alright. AirTag.
It's going in the pocket.
List of tasks is on our phones.
We haven't read it yet.
Yes.
One hour.
It doesn't seem like a lot of time.
Good luck, Arun.
Your time starts in 3, 2, 1.
Go!
Okay, see ya!
And I gotta keep looking this way.
I've just gotta stand
next to the wall here now
and just not look at anything.
I've got five minutes now.
(breathless laughing)
Let's run.
At the very least, I can outpace Tom.
Let's see what we've got.
"AirTag rematch tasks."
Okay, now I need to
pull up this list of tasks.
Where do I need to go?
Oh, now I know how Tom felt.
My god!
"Take a trip to the oldest inn in England".
Right, that's Ye Olde Trip to Jerusalem.
I know that.
So that might be
somewhere worth going.
"Oldest inn in England."
I know where that is.
These tasks are much
less location specific.
A lot of these could happen anywhere.
So one of the rules of this game
is that I can only take every
form of public transport once.
Gotta be very tactical about this.
In theory, I could just sit by the
Robin Hood statue for 45 minutes,
but he could just see me and run
and get everything everywhere else.
In fact, if he's aiming right for
the Robin Hood statue,
he's either gotta get it very quickly,
so I can't possibly catch up with him,
or he knows I can wait for him there,
so that would be a bad move on his part.
"Find a piece of art."
To be honest, there'll be
a piece of art in any building!
There. That counts, right?
I think my only option is to
actually track him with the AirTag.
So I think I just gotta
wait out the five minutes,
and see where he is going.
Which is really stressful!
I was really hoping to
plan ahead here!
I'm just gonna text Tom
to tell him we've done one,
and we've only had
four minutes!
One?!
He's already completed a task,
and I haven't even set off yet!
What can he have done within
three minutes of here?
What I'm gonna try and do is
to complete the less specific tasks
on the way to the more specific tasks.
So let's try and find
a gift for Tom.
I mean, the gift could be anything.
If I don't get an AirTag update,
then my only option
in 26 seconds' time...
...is to run for the Robin Hood statue
and just keep checking in
and hope he's gone that way.
I've had no update from the AirTag.
Shop, shop, shop, shop, shop.
Okay. There's a Tesco
across the road.
Aha.
I forgot to turn my phone
on airplane mode.
No!
Three.
Two.
One.
I'm gonna try and follow him.
So the way these AirTags work is
they send out a Bluetooth signal
that's picked up by nearby iPhones,
and it's those iPhones that then
beam the location to the internet.
So the fact that I've had my phone's
data on this whole time is not good.
Okay. We went the right way.
We went the right way.
I've got an update.
He's this way.
Two. He's got a
second task already.
Right.
The statue, he must have
posed with the statue here.
He knew where
the statue was, I didn't.
That's home turf advantage.
He's gotta run that way
at some point.
He's got Ye Olde Trip to Jerusalem
down there, which is the oldest pub.
And he's got the Robin Hood statue.
I've got no other updates.
We gotta head that way.
Robin Hood statue.
Okay.
Does that count?
Yes. Okay.
So, oh, now I've gotta
text him three.
Wait, there's another thing
I can do here.
Anyone who thinks that an AirTag
is a good real time tracker...
Absolutely not.
Okay.
I found another statue.
What are you doing?
Does that count?
Okay, cool.
Not what I thought
I'd be doing today. Let's go.
He's already on three!
It's what, ten minutes in,
he's already on three.
I'm nowhere near him.
Find My.
What?
That can't be right.
I need to text him four.
I need to get some cover,
cuz he's definitely coming this way.
There's no way he doesn't
know where we are.
I've got no idea where he is.
Was he hidden in a doorway or
somewhere back there
and saw me run...?
No good at stealth!
Four?!
We need to go back to
town centre now.
Well, we need to take a route
that we know avoids Tom.
Agh!
It's infuriating.
It is absolutely infuriating.
The AirTag just is not tracking him.
Okay, I think our best bet is to go
the opposite way he would expect us to go,
jump in an Uber and use that to
get past him going back.
No updates in eight minutes.
Come on, this is meant
to do better than that.
Gotta turn my data back on.
This is anxiety inducing.
I'm just force-closing
and reopening Find My,
in the hope it forces an
update from something.
Okay, taxi is...
Ah, three minutes away.
Can we— Oh, Jerusalem Inn.
This is the oldest pub.
So it's, "Take a trip to
the oldest inn in England."
Okay. There we go. Good trip.
He hasn't got any tasks in a while.
Let's look at the list.
What's he— What will he have got?
"Find Tom a piece—" Five!
Okay. I've just texted him five,
while we were in the oldest inn.
There's no way he doesn't know
where we are right now.
Oh, god.
I'm hyper paranoid right now.
Every single person who's
walking past,
I'm double checking
to see if it's Tom.
We got an update. He was...
What?
Nine minutes ago,
he was heading down that way.
He's on a bus, or he's on a tram,
headed to Nottingham Castle.
He's gotta be going for the
Robin Hood statue. He's got to be.
We've...
I've gotta run to the Robin Hood statue.
It's the only option I've got.
Which is this way.
You ready for an uphill run?
We're going to a castle.
So we are
fourteen minutes in.
And we've already done
five of the eight tasks.
This feels good.
He must be panicking right now.
If this is a wrong bet,
I'm done for!
Okay.
Thank god, okay.
We're okay.
Okay. I'll get on the other side.
Okay. We got our car.
He went this way!
I know he went this way.
'Cause twelve minutes ago,
the AirTag pinged
where we were by the statue.
Ten minutes ago, it pinged
somewhere on this street.
We are in our car.
There is no Tom to be seen.
The AirTag just told me that I'd
left Arun behind somewhere.
Damn right, I did.
That's the statue.
We are headed to the shops.
So I'm gonna try and get
a change of clothing.
And I also need to dance
with a busker,
which I can safely say
I've never done before.
Four minutes ago,
he was up there.
He was up there.
He was coming for the statue.
Has he made it here yet?
So at this point, I'm now gonna
turn my airplane mode on.
Update, dammit!
So Tom will think that this is the
last location we're at right now.
We're about to leave him
behind and go into town.
Come on, AirTag.
I should have run here.
I had the plan.
I was gonna run here right away.
And I thought, no, I'll wait
for the AirTag tracker.
This is thrilling.
Oh, I'm an idiot!
Ye Olde Trip to Jerusalem,
the pub.
The oldest pub is just up there.
And that's exactly where his
AirTag was five minutes ago.
And I was so fixated on the statue.
I didn't think to check that location.
So I've only really got two tasks
I can do in town,
which is gonna take us
to seven.
I need to make sure I know
what the eighth is gonna be.
He can't be coming for the statue.
If he was this close, he would've
got the statue by now.
So where's he going instead?
List of tasks.
(car horn)
Welcome to Nottingham.
Why haven't I seen an update?
Where could he have gone?
If he's down Nottingham Caves,
I'll be very impressed.
He must be thinking,
"Where are they?"
I mean, if it's any consolation...
I imagine he'll be panicking
that I'm right behind him.
And...
Yeah, no!
What's helping this time is that
it is a smaller city,
and you're spending
less time in transport.
Although it doesn't really
feel like it right now.
Let's head back towards
the town centre.
Either he's got these
or he is not getting these.
If I head back towards
the town centre, chances are,
I'll be closer to
wherever the next ping is.
Who knows?
This clothing task is probably
gonna be one of the longer tasks.
But if I change my outfit,
that is going to guarantee
my safety.
It's not giving me any
information right now.
How can he not have done
a task in like ten minutes?
Where's he going?
What's he doing?
Is he...
Is he in a cab?
Is he on a bus?
Good to go. Okay.
Let's find a shop.
How has he avoided all people
with iPhones for 11 minutes?
Unfortunately, we are gonna have to go
right into the centre of town
to get an outfit,
which is gonna expose us,
but I'm hoping that Uber ride
threw Tom off.
Hello and welcome
to twenty minutes
of Tom looking down
at his phone confused.
If you want to take your career
in a new direction,
then you may want to have a look at
this video's sponsor, Boolean.
In short, they'll teach you to code.
Boolean are a career-focused
tech academy with live, online classes.
Their courses last between ten weeks and
six months, full-time or part-time.
You can choose between front-end development,
full stack, or data analytics.
And the final classes of the year
are starting soon on November the 7th.
It's designed to start your career,
which means there's a heavy focus on
practical work during the course.
Their teachers are people who've
done the job and have industry experience.
Plus you have the option to pay
only when you actually get hired
at the end of the course.
Or if you pay upfront,
you're covered by their refund guarantee.
If you apply to jobs and don't get hired,
they'll refund you.
So if you're seriously considering
taking the next step in your career,
and joining a fast-growing
industry like tech,
you may want to consider signing up for
Boolean's last cohort of the year.
And if you start the application process
before 30th of September,
they'll also give you a
£500 early bird discount.
There's a link on screen
and in the description.
Good luck for your future.
Right, back to me
chasing Arun in Nottingham.
It's been fifteen minutes
since Arun did a task.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
They all went really, really quickly.
They went within nine
minutes of each other.
Now it's been
fifteen more minutes,
and he's not ticked
a single one off.
And...
This way!
I was right.
Heading back towards town
was the right thing.
One minute ago, he was—
(softly) He was around that corner
one minute ago.
Come on, come on,
come on.
I'm getting so scared right now
heading right into the middle of town.
This is not good.
Okay, I just need to slip
into this shop here.
I want to buy myself the
plainest outfit possible.
This will do very nicely.
Almost camo. I'll be invisible.
Okay. Let's get XXL.
If he did a task around
this corner, they're headed up.
That's fine.
Just those are great.
Thank you so much.
No, I'm being chased for a challenge.
It's— I'm safe, I promise.
He was right here.
He was exactly here
two minutes ago.
Do you guys have a changing room?
You do. Okay, fantastic.
I'm still whispering
because for all I know,
he might be down
one of these alleyways.
Oh god. Okay.
I've gotta change fast.
I'm very vulnerable
when I'm stuck in this store.
You know when I said,
he was right there?
The tag moved!
While I was talking to camera,
the tag moved. He's down here.
He's just down here.
Alright, I'm in the changing room.
Probably not gonna wanna watch this.
Okay, I'm done.
I look ridiculous right now.
He was here!
Just realised I also need a hat.
That'll do the trick.
I'm gonna get a hat as well.
If he tripped the AirTag,
got a task over there,
avoided people,
sent me on a wild goose chase to here
and is now running to the castle, I swear.
Yes, I'm being chased. Yeah.
It's a YouTuber.
I'm gonna take a punt.
I'm gonna head down
to the Broadmarsh,
which is like the one bit
of Nottingham I remember.
'Cause I've been there as a kid.
I'm gonna head down towards
the Broadmarsh...
...in the hope that he went
vaguely this way.
Let's get that on. Alright.
I look ridiculous.
Oh, thank you.
Okay, bye-bye.
Is he here? Did you see him?
You look very scared right now.
Can we get outta here then?
Arun is either a tactical genius,
or he's just randomly panicking
and running places.
And I don't know what the...
Broadmarsh is gone.
Number six is done.
Just texted Tom,
which unfortunately means
he's now gonna have an update
on where we are.
Okay. What next?
Well, okay. Didn't expect
to have my childhood
wrenched from me here,
but we move on.
Arun's not in the Broadmarsh.
It's— Six.
That challenge took
longer than expected.
We only have 25 minutes
left to do the final two.
I also have a suspicion
he's very close.
I'm gonna head vaguely this way,
which is back towards the castle.
I know we were there earlier.
Gotta get off these
main roads ASAP.
If Arun's smart, and he is,
then he will be quietly
wandering around Nottingham
with a smile on his face and a
game plan for his last two tasks.
Knowing that I'm in the dark, or at least
suspecting that I'm in the dark.
He will be going stealthily.
He will be looking over his shoulder.
He'll be sneaking down back alleyways.
Hopefully, if we can get up there,
we'll get a view of the windmill.
We're YouTubers.
I think he said,
"What are you doing?"
Okay, yes. I think we can get
a stained glass window in here.
There was a new tag four minutes ago,
back where I was...
If I'd have just stayed there!
Ah, my hat!
How— That's not part—
None of this makes sense!
Take— Find a stained glass window.
Okay. I mean...
That counts, right?
Cool.
Seven.
He's not gonna be happy
about that.
Seven.
That's it, he needs
one more task to win.
With time to spare.
And I don't have the faintest
idea where he is.
Think when I get up here,
I'll be able to see the windmill.
Oh god, I really hope so.
Oh no!
There's a giant building in the way.
No!
Surely not, surely not.
Oh no, no!
Aah!
Student accommodation.
That way. He's gone that way.
But... but that was
four minutes ago!
We're very exposed on this road.
There's not a lot of people,
but on the plus side,
that should mean
the AirTag will ping less.
Cause there's less iPhones we're passing.
He was right here five minutes ago.
I'm trying to actually use the thing that...
that searches the AirTag's actual signal,
but he is not anywhere around here.
I know it's that way.
You just can't see it!
He's nowhere near Shakespeare Street.
He's nowhere near the
Robin Hood statue.
oldest inn in England.
I think he got all those
before I got there.
I really want to turn on
Google Maps so I can check,
but then Tom, then Tom will be
right onto me with no escape.
He'll know exactly where I'm going.
Yikes.
He's that way.
He's that way. Five minutes—
It's so frustrating.
If these were live,
I might stand a chance, but...
Okay, my data is now on.
I'm exposed.
Let me just quickly...
need to quickly check this windmill.
If he got on a tram, I'm done for.
I'll never catch him.
Alright. Final sprint.
I'm pretty— We're nearby now.
Let's do it.
Oh, I ran the wrong way.
That's helpful(!)
He didn't go this way.
He went that way.
If I'm really lucky, I can cut him off,
down here, but it's just gonna be luck.
I know I've said this like four times,
but I'm pretty sure,
next corner we turn,
there will be a windmill.
We're back here again.
We're back at the crossroads.
We've just looped round in a
figure-eight, chasing shadows.
Chasing minutes-old shadows.
Oh god!
Realised my data's been on
this entire time.
Why do I keep doing this?
I might just get an ice cream.
Come on. Come on.
Windmill!
Yes. Yes. I see it.
Okay.
Let's take a photo.
Selfie, selfie.
Oh god. Oh god.
Okay. We need to get closer.
This is heart wrenching stuff.
Come on. Come on.
Yes.
Okay. That counts, right?
That's the windmill!
Redemption feels so good.
Okay. Let's give Tom a ring.
Is that eight?
That is eight, Thomas.
I never stood a chance.
Ohh, well done.
Also, nice hat.
Thank you.
Do you wanna come and meet me
by St. Peter's Church,
and...
We'll see you in a minute.
Yes. Yeah, sure.
Okay, see you there.
He's changed at least one item
of clothing, possibly two.
I wonder if I was anywhere near him.
Here we go, here we go.
You like my getup?
I mean...
Good hat.
With this on, yeah.
No, I completely—
(church bells ringing)
You can even actually invert it.
And that's time.
Chimes the bell.
I had two problems.
One is that there were
ten minute gaps.
Yeah.
Where I just saw nothing.
I had the same thing in London.
But also when it did update,
it said five minutes ago.
Yep. Been there.
It just...
I got a flurry of updates
within a couple of minutes
just all around this area and I
looped around three or four times.
Mm.
Interesting, that.
Oh no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, you did.
So the fantastic getup
that Arun managed to get
is from that shop there.
From Blacks?!
Yes.    From Blacks.
I was stood—!
We know.
I know you were stood there,
because while he was in Blacks,
I got this footage of you two.
Wait, the two camera ops
saw each other?!
That's fantastic.
Oh, here's your gift by the way.
I brought you tingly mint
& tea tree shampoo.
Thanks.
It's been a hot day today.
Thanks. Yeah.
Well done, Arun.
Good game.
Let's go to the pub.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]